[Applauso]
[Musica]
Buon pomeriggio a tutti e buon
pomeriggio a tutti
vi siete mai posti questa domanda Come è
formato il sistema educativo nazionale
italiano è una domanda importante
Noi abbiamo circa 9 milioni di studenti
che frequentano tutti i 4 livelli
scolastici dall'asilo fino alla scuola
secondaria superiore abbiamo circa un
milione e 9700.000 studenti che
frequentano l'università adesso si
aggiungono circa un milione di
insegnanti in totale complessivamente il
nostro sistema formativo è composto da
12 milioni di persone il 20% della
popolazione
Evidentemente si tratta di un contesto
che avrebbe bisogno di particolare
attenzione e di enormi investimenti da
parte del paese ed essi dovrebbero
orientarsi verso tre direzioni
sicuramente le infrastrutture fisiche le
scuole Le aule ma anche le architetture
quelle virtuali il cloud ma soprattutto
il terzo investimento quello forse più
importante verso gli insegnanti In modo
tale da consentire loro di percorsi di
crescita digitale e professionale ma
anche importante anche garantire agli
insegnanti uno stipendio che sia
adeguato a quella che è la media Europea
voi voi tutti Nel 2020 avete imparato
Qual è il significato di Didattica a
distanza
La didattica a distanza nasce laddove ci
sono enormi distanze geografiche da
colmare e non è un caso proprio che la
principale piattaforma per il learning
Moodle che è stato inventata vent'anni
fa sia stata proprio creata in Australia
da parte di uno studente che aveva
frequentato gran parte del suo percorso
proprio a distanza
e i materiali didattici gli venivano
recapitati via aereo ogni settimana ma
quella che tutti noi abbiamo conosciuto
in questi ultimi anni non è la didattica
a distanza
si può chiamare solo ed esclusivamente
didattica in emergenza
la Dad o la formazione a distanza Lat
FAD o il Digital Learning sono altri
concetti ma sono proprio questi punti
che necessiterebbero di forti
investimenti sia dal punto di vista
tecnologico sia dal punto di vista
pedagogico
È però importante garantire
l'accessibilità della formazione per
tutti e per tutto con il concetto di
tutti Intendo tutti coloro che non
possono uscire dalla propria abitazione
tutti coloro che hanno qualche forma di
disabilità tutti coloro che sono
temporaneamente ammalati o che hanno
delle necessità lavorative o familiari o
personali Ecco il significato di
inclusione però non dovete pensarlo Come
creare
processi tecnologie esclusivamente per
il mondo dei disabili pensare in modo
inclusivo serve a semplificare attività
tutte le attività tutti i processi e per
tutti
però ci vorrebbe veramente un
cambiamento di rotta da tanti punti di
vista
e il cambiamento però è difficile da
digerire sia quando esso è sequenziale
graduale progressivo sia soprattutto
diventa più complesso quando esso è
netto è
radicale disruptive si dice in inglese
il cambiamento che porta a una rottura
quello sì è difficile da assecondare per
tutti noi
però è quello che ci vorrebbe in un
momento storico come questo per il
nostro paese
[Musica]
Come genere umano Noi siamo
biologicamente Preparati predisposti a
un cambiamento esclusivamente graduale
molto lento perché è veramente facile
che in caso di un cambiamento repentino
sorga Naturalmente una sorta di
repulsione di un rifiuto e di fatto quel
mutamento quel cambiamento diventi un
fallimento non abbia successo È
veramente facile
più di quanto potete immaginare che un
tablet possa diventare un semplice
vassoio
Ma non si può parlare Purtroppo nel
nostro paese di vera e profonda
trasformazione digitale che fra l'altro
il tema è uno dei temi cardini del Piano
Nazionale di ripresa resilienza del
paese perché purtroppo l'Italia è ancora
agli ultimi posti lo vedete
dall'immagine Per quanto riguarda
l'alfabetizzazione digitale e la
crescita di un'economia e di una società
digitale
è vero anche che il piano nazionale di
ripresa resilienza prende origine è
stato disegnato sull'impronta di un
altro progetto molto importante europeo
quello che ci dà i finanziamenti il Next
Generation non è un caso che si chiama
proprio generazione prossima generazione
Futura
Ma a sua volta questo piano prende
spunto da un'altra analisi dell'Unione
Europea la bussola digitale 2030
l'Europa chiede a tutti i paesi di
grandi investimenti nell'infrastruttura
e tecnologiche per migliorare le imprese
e per favorire la nascita di nuovi
servizi tecnologici nella pubblica
amministrazione ma tutte queste parti
sono pensate per far crescere quelle che
sono le competenze digitali dei
cittadini di tutti noi le cosiddette
Digital soft skill l'Unione Europea
ipotizza che entro il 2030
l'80% dei cittadini dovrà possedere
queste competenze ma l'Unione Europea ci
dice anche a stimato che attualmente
sono impiegati Circa 7 milioni e 800.000
persone nel mondo del lavoro per quanto
riguarda le tecnologie Ebbene questo
numero nel 2030 dovrà essere oltre 20
milioni si tratta di una dimensione che
tre volte tanto il 2030 non è il futuro
che noi ci immaginiamo è veramente
dietro l'angolo è domani
ma il 2020 anche è stato un anno
sicuramente drammatico da tanti punti di
vista ma per quanto concerne il contesto
formativo è stato un anno dove si è
verificato un salto tecnologico e sono
venuto con l'utilizzo di strumenti
tecnologici digitali da parte degli
insegnanti da parte degli studenti un
po' da parte di tutti Ma per chi come me
si occupa di tecnologie il salto l'ha
vissuto per quanto riguarda gli spazi e
le archiviazioni di dati abbiamo
archiviato una montagna di dati e
soprattutto in
tipologia di video
ho ipotizzato che in soli 4 mesi abbiamo
compiuto un salto tecnologico pari a 8
anni voi tutti Siete abituati a
considerare l'unità di misura del
gigabyte Perché quella con cui vi
rapportate con il telefonino con il
computer nelle aziende diciamo di medie
e grandi dimensioni Noi siamo abituati
tutti a trattare la dimensione del
terabyte Ebbene in poche settimane nel
precedenti Siamo passati dal terabyte
alla dimensione del petabyte Credetemi e
si tratta di una dimensione che
probabilmente a voi non vi dice poco ma
io non avrei mai pensato di doverla
gestire e soprattutto così tanti anni
prima di andare in pensione
e
tutto questo scenario comportato
sicuramente un aumento di quelle che
sono le professionalità e le competenze
digitali di tutti
degli insegnanti e degli studenti di
tutti voi adesso è diventata la
normalità a parlare di fronte a una
telecamera come stiamo facendo anche
come sto facendo anche in questo momento
ma non lo era mai stato prima non era
mai stato nemmeno per coloro che si
occupavano di formazione appunto
insegnanti e formatori
Finora abbiamo affrontato tre tematiche
abbiamo parlato di formazione di scuola
abbiamo parlato del mondo del lavoro di
quelle che saranno le necessità
occupazionali del futuro e abbiamo
parlato soprattutto di investimenti che
il paese dovrebbe portare
e abbiamo compreso che in realtà
l'apprendimento e la formazione È un
processo che non termina mai che
continua sempre e infatti si apprende si
studia per crescere per trovare una
propria collocazione all'interno del
mondo in particolare il mondo del lavoro
poi si continua a studiare per cambiare
magari la propria occupazione o per
migliorare la propria professionalità e
infine Questo è veramente importante
continuare a studiare per inseguire
quelli che sono i propri sogni proprio
obiettivi i propri desideri lettitudini
questo è il concetto di Life Long
Learning o apprendimento permanente
costante continuo e Questa rappresenta
anche la vera sfida per la formazione
del futuro
ma il Life Long Learning Anzi si tratta
tutto questo è uno scenario
effettivamente particolarmente
articolato che probabilmente voi tutti
avrete già affrontato tutti voi Sarà
capitato di
di
lavorare all'interno di aule e di
studiare all'interno di contesti
articolati ebbene con il Life Long
Learning dovremmo capovolgere tutte le
strutture e le
e i modi con cui sia preso finora
Dovremo pensare a lezioni che non hanno
più un inizio una fine non dovremmo più
pensare delle aule fisico delle aule
virtuali la formazione dovrà essere
sempre disponibile e ovunque
perché farà fondamentale riuscire a
conciliare quelli che sono i tempi di
lavoro le esigenze familiari gli impegni
personali e pertanto la formazione dovrà
essere garantita nei ritagli di tempo
durante gli spostamenti o mentre si
cucina
[Musica]
voi tutti Probabilmente un anticipo di
questo scenario l'avete già toccato con
mano voi tutti Avete già probabilmente
provato o gran parte di voi gli
audiolibri i podcast o alcuni avranno
frequentato i mouk in Messico online
Open corsis pensate che
in tutto il mondo ci sono oltre 50
piattaforme tecnologiche che offrono
circa 60.000 corsi
su tutto lo scibile umano sono corsi
gratuiti disponibili in tutte le lingue
e che hanno visto negli ultimi anni
oltre
220.000 milioni di partecipanti Ecco
questa è il concetto di formazione on
demand si tratta di insegnamenti di
materie disponibili
sempre ovunque in base a quelle che sono
le proprie necessità di crescita per
capire meglio proprio il concetto però
di formazione on demand provate a
pensare al cambiamento che c'è stato nel
mondo della televisione Con l'avvento di
piattaforme digitali on demand proprio
come Sky come Netflix come dazn Amazon
Prime oppure nel mondo della musica
della radio con Spotify Ebbene ora
chiunque di voi anche in questo momento
alla libertà di scegliere di guardare un
programma qualsiasi ascoltare la canzone
che più gli piace e questo lo può fare
sempre e ovunque e soprattutto anche da
ogni dispositivo Ecco il mio messaggio
quindi per il futuro
dice proprio formazione on demand on
demand Learning sempre e ovunque ovunque
Dove c'è banda e dove c'è connettività
chiaramente
Ma qualsiasi voce da e per il futuro
dovrà basarsi sempre su solidi principi
etici e mi piace chiudere questo
intervento citando l'Università degli
Studi di Padova che è la mia istituzione
che quest'anno compie 800 anni Ecco
all'articolo 1 del proprio statuto Cita
come essa promuove
l'elaborazione di una cultura fondata su
valori universali e questi valori sono
quattro sono i diritti umani la pace la
salvaguardia dell'ambiente e la
solidarietà internazionale Ecco io
ritengo che questi quattro fattori
questi quattro elementi siano gli
elementi cardine perché sono più
importanti di qualsiasi tecnologia sono
la base per qualsiasi insegnamento e
soprattutto devono rappresentare quelle
che sono i principi ispiratori di
qualsiasi voce da e per il nostro futuro
grazie
[Applauso]